So who's my guest this week?
It's Nyle DiMarco.
From America's Top Model to
Oscar nominated film producer,
he's become an ambassador for deaf pride,
taking on the hearing
world on his own terms.
He's fourth generation deaf
choosing not to communicate vocally
and has long challenged the
notion that learning to sign
can hinder the ability to speak English.
His memoir "Deaf Utopia" is a love letter
to American sign language,
explaining why he doesn't
think deafness needs fixing.
You're going to hear why competing
in America's Next Top Model was "hell"
and why he's pretty
annoyed with Will Smith.
Did you see the slap?
We're talking about Will
Smith of course, here.
Oh, I did in fact see it all.
I mean, I think everyone in the audience
was quite confused initially.
It seemed like a joke
or like a scripted bit.
But no.
As soon as Will Smith started screaming,
my interpreter let me know
and everybody went quiet and I thought,
"What are you doing
stealing our spotlight?
Come on Will."
Yeah, I was gonna say.
That must have been,
I mean, were you actually
annoyed about that?
Was anyone frustrated
in the deaf community?
Because it really was the thing.
Yeah, certainly.
Yeah, it was my first thought.
I felt like, you know,
this is such a historic moment
and it really felt like a moment for us.
And I thought, "At least
let us have this one night."
But you know, it's very
typical for hearing people
to wanna center themselves
and ask us to just orbit them.
Nyle DiMarco, welcome to the program.
It's really good to have you on the show.
And I should say,
we'll be speaking to each other
through an interpreter today.
But what I wanted to start by asking you,
right at the heart of your book,
the title no less is
what would a deaf utopia
look like to you?
Good morning, a deaf utopia I think for me
would certainly look like a place where
we all have complete access.
Which means a world
inclusive of sign language,
but also with accessible features
that make deaf people feel like we
can really connect and
belong on this planet.
What does that mean?
I suppose what I'm asking is
what don't we have at the moment?
Well, I'd say some of the things
that we don't have just in general
is a lack of deaf culture awareness.
So many people that I meet who are hearing
in conversation often remind me
that they don't know
that deaf culture exists.
They don't really realize
that we have a community
and from their perspective,
deafness is a disability and
couldn't possibly be inclusive
of a culture, which in fact is not true.
We have a language which
gives rise to culture.
I think essentially that really starts
with a lack of awareness.
You also mentioned there the need for sign
to be better understood
or better recognized.
Are you talking about in a deaf utopia,
everyone would be able to
have some kind of literacy?
Yeah, I mean, essentially
I would love that.
You know, I think that's probably one of
the biggest goals that we
really have as a community.
You know, sign language
has incredible benefits
for hearing people and for
deaf people alike, right?
In sign language we can
speak and communicate faster
than in English.
We can also talk through
windows and underwater,
how cool is that?
Yes, it really is.
I hadn't thought about that at all.
But yeah, there are
other things I'll come to
from some of your stories about some of
the benefits people may not have realized,
not least having a party at home
without your mom knowing
because you could just shut
the door and go for it.
And I think some of those
examples are amazing.
Yeah, you know, honestly
we call that #deafgames.
You know, being from a
deaf family is incredible
but it's also incredibly rare.
And I think kids like me tend to abuse it.
My mom being such a good sleeper
was really helpful for us
when we wanted to rage
at four or five o'clock in the morning.
I mean, you mentioned your family.
You're fourth generation deaf.
What did that mean
growing up in your family
with how you learned to communicate
and the culture around you?
Definitely.
Being born to an entirely deaf family
and having deaf parents meant
that I had access to language day one.
To be honest, I don't really remember
first learning to sign
like many other people
don't really remember
their first words either.
It's something that I
wanted to hear your view on
because we've just been
through a pandemic.
I mean, we're still in it in lots of ways
and people were having to homeschool
and then I imagine for those children
didn't have access to the deaf
schools and to their peers,
to the people that they
were used to being with.
Absolutely, absolutely.
And it's a great point.
It was a very large
problem in the community.
Deaf schools all over were
faced with an entirely new issue
of how they bring the
exposure to the parents
and how do they bring them in home?
How do they provide access to language
and continue exposing them to our culture
and continue to give
them not only exposure to
their role models, but also
the ability to socialize.
Having to send those
children home to a place
where they couldn't practice sign
was in many ways traumatic
for so many kids out there.
And an entirely new issue that
we faced with the pandemic,
you're absolutely right.
I suppose the other thing as well,
and I wonder if you had
an experience with this,
is everyone was wearing masks
and a lot of people still are.
Was that difficult for
you during the pandemic?
Definitely, definitely.
You know, for me in everyday life,
I depend on lip reading often, you know?
And honestly, lip reading is certainly not
the best way to communicate.
If you look at any of the statistics,
you see that even the best of lip readers
can only catch about 30%.
But suddenly with a mask, I was at zero.
So, all of the guess work was gone.
Of course it was frustrating,
but I think all of us really
were in this together.
Yes, well, it's lovely to
be able to see your face.
Likewise.
Yes
Happy to take those off, for sure.
And it's nice to be able
to see people's faces now.
Yeah, exactly.
And some of the real expressions.
I'm obviously minded of the fact
that a lot of people
really liked your face
because you won "America's
Next Top Model."
That's something that we should bring up.
But I wonder when going onto that program,
were you thinking about
how it was going to work?
That you
don't talk in the sense of
how some people were gonna
then find it to communicate with you?
Absolutely, absolutely.
It was honestly one of the
first things that I considered.
I remember when "America's Next Top Model"
first reached out to me for the audition.
I ignored it.
You know, of course, any
type of reality TV show
and certainly a competition,
I felt like wasn't going to
be ready for a deaf person.
I certainly had never
seen one on TV before.
But, you know, they
reached out multiple times
and finally I responded and said,
"Are you really ready
for a deaf contestant
in the first place?"
They said, "Yes."
So, I started the journey,
but of course it was tough.
I did have an interpreter on
set, but only 10% of the time.
Meaning 90% of the time I was lacking
the ability to really communicate fully.
I don't think they really understood
the accessibility needs
that really came along
with a deaf contestant, but
also how to accommodate.
And so much of it just
comes with, you know,
reality TV shows the, you
know, psychological warfare,
the mind games, you know,
the causing drama to make better TV.
And I certainly get that perspective.
But I survived through four months of it.
And would I do it again?
No, I'd rather not walk through hell.
Not walk through hell?
Why hell?
Well, I'll tell you.
Four months, I mean,
imagine for four months
you could only use,
say spoken English for 10% of the time.
I was texting back and
forth with everybody else,
which is incredibly limited.
I mean, think about how
fast we can text, right?
It doesn't really carry
like a conversation.
So to only be able to use
your language about 10%
of the time, you know,
your language that gives
you not only dignity,
but who you are.
It's, you know, your self-confidence,
your pride and your ability to express.
I think that the minute you
start to think about that
you would feel incredibly isolated if
that had been your experience.
And yet you could also
be forgiven to think
being a model is perhaps
a good profession in
the sense of at least
you don't have to talk
when you're doing the modeling part.
Right, right.
Exactly.
And to be honest with you,
it was an incredibly isolating experience.
But I think in the end, I really
was planning for a result.
I was looking forward to the end
and not only to win for myself,
but also to win for the community
and to be able to elevate
the amount of awareness
of our culture and our community.
Which I think really was more important.
You know, honestly,
modeling as a deaf person,
there's a lot of benefits, right?
I come from a very visual culture
where we study body language.
So it's definitely a different level
being able to study a photographer
and what they're looking for
and also to be able to emulate the poses.
I mean, body language is
really what we're experts at.
Yeah, you know, I'm
now just thinking about
how I'm sitting, what I'm
giving off to you here.
I'm gonna think this through a bit more,
but it's one of those things
that it must be a bit of a superpower.
Oh, absolutely.
Absolutely.
And if you take a look at
any of the articles out there
about deaf people's peripheral vision,
you'll actually see that
studies have been done to show
that it's enhanced, it's widened.
We actually see more and we take more of
the world in than hearing people.
So yeah, we're superheroes.
You'll take that, I'm sure.
And it's something, you know, again,
to think about a different
way of seeing the world
and actually reading the
world while you're in it.
You also of course, are known
for "Dancing with the Stars"
and music it seems, again,
if you haven't thought
about the deaf world,
the deaf culture, is an
incredibly important part
of being in the world.
And it's that experience I
understand of feeling the beat.
Well, I mean, personally, do I feel,
if you're asking if I
could feel the beat on set?
I'll be honest.
I couldn't hear or feel anything.
So, our rehearsals were
pretty interesting in that
we had to practice using other systems.
We would often use larger studios
that were quite wide open.
And the system that Peta and
I developed was counting.
It was just simple math.
But we also shared a cue
system that we developed.
For example, if Peta taps me,
that was say to begin the routine.
A hand squeeze would mean
that we were going to switch
specific formation or footwork.
Scratch on my back might
have meant that I was late.
So to the audience at home,
of course, nobody noticed.
But if you go back and
watch some of the reruns,
you'll be able to catch
some of those cues.
But for some people
they do talk about being
able to feel some of
the beat but you couldn't feel anything.
Right. It really just
depends on where you are.
So my twin brother actually,
who is also deaf, is a DJ.
If you can believe, has an amazing
brilliant professional setup.
That's like something like 2000 Watts.
It's absolutely insane.
But on dancing with the stars,
I couldn't feel anything like
what he can in the DJ booth.
But you know,
there was a moment certainly
where we had a couple NFL
dancers who came on,
which was really great.
And the funny thing was, they
couldn't catch their footwork.
Right. They just couldn't
get the timing right.
And at the end, I couldn't hear any of it.
I couldn't feel any of it.
And I was still able to keep
the math perfectly on time,
which is kind of ironic. Right.
I'm the only one in the
room who can't hear.
And yet I'm matching.
Yeah. Well, congratulations
belatedly for, for that,
because it was obviously
a huge success as well,
but I suppose what's been
driving your work as well to this
point because you've been working
now as a producer as well.
Oscar nominated,
congratulations for "Audible" on Netflix.
Thank you very much.
I mean, that must have
been quite the night,
especially because of
"CODA" as well, winning.
Oh, it was incredible.
It was incredible.
And truly a watershed
moment for our community.
If you consider that it's
been 35 years since we've had
another member of the deaf community
take to the Oscar stage,
it's really incredible.
Marlee Matlin's work in this industry.
I mean, really, truly speaks for itself.
But that night we had over 10
deaf people on the red carpet.
It was incredible to see that
amount of representation.
And the wins that night, I mean,
if you consider three
wins alone from "CODA"
was really groundbreaking.
And I think it shows that the time is now,
it really feels that people,
it really feels like people at home
are really hungry for our stories.
And we're really looking
to make this a movement
rather than a moment.
I think right now we have to
start bringing deaf people in
behind the camera.
Right?
Which is so key to authenticity
because that truly is where
it begins.
Yes.
Although the Oscars this
year also bring to mind
something else.
I was wondering, did you,
did you see the slap?
We're talking about Will
Smith of course here.
Oh, I did.
In fact see it all.
I mean,
I think everyone in the
audience was quite confused
initially. It seemed like a
joke or like a scripted bit,
but no, soon as Will
Smith started screaming,
my interpreter let me know.
And everybody went quiet and I thought,
"What are you doing stealing
our spotlight? Come on Will."
Yeah, I was gonna say, that
must have been, I mean,
were you actually annoyed about that?
Was anyone frustrated in the,
the deaf community because
it really was the thing.
Yeah, certainly it was, yeah, it was my,
it was my first thought.
I felt like, you know,
this is such a historic moment
and it really felt like a
moment for us.
And I thought, "At least
let us have this one night."
But you know, it's very
typical for hearing people
to want to center themselves
and ask us to just orbit them.
Yeah.
Although I'm also now trying
to imagine your interpreter
telling you what Will Smith was saying
and you getting that as well,
because if you could hear
it and see it, it was,
as you said, you didn't believe it.
No, absolutely.
Absolutely. So during the Oscars,
they had two large TV
screens on both sides,
And so I was able to see Will.
Because they had panned over
to him and I could clearly see
a reaction of what was going on.
But when I asked my
interpreter what he was saying,
it became very evident
that it was not a scripted bit at all.
Yeah, and you definitely
didn't need to be able to hear
to understand the last bit right?
Talking about body language.
Right. Definitely, definitely immediately.
And I could lip read him on
the, on the cameras as well.
It was loud, clear as day.
It was, yeah.
Well, quite the moment.
But as you say,
quite the moment for the deaf
community as well that night,
and I know that you also
feel very passionately.
You say about people behind the camera,
but also on the camera, you are
of the view that deaf actors
should be playing the deaf roles?
Absolutely.
Definitely, definitely.
I mean,
I don't think that deaf people
only ever have to play deaf
roles certainly,
but I think that auditions
should be open to everyone,
including members of our community.
And I think we're at a point
where we shouldn't be hiring,
hearing people to play
a deaf role, certainly.
So many people, I think,
assume that it's easy to take
on the role of a deaf person.
But, can they actually really go in there
and kill the audition?
I don't think so, right?
Often times people are learning
sign language a few minutes
ahead of time and, you know,
sign language takes
years and years and years
to be able to really become fluent in.
But also there's a cultural
nuance that's really ingrained
in us that I think really
shows on the screen.
I had a son a few years ago
and we went to a baby sign class.
And the reason the woman had
started the class was because
her sister was deaf.
So she had signed her whole life.
And it was an amazing way to
communicate with your child
and you know, we are not deaf,
but I greatly enjoyed the class.
It's fantastic.
A lot of people, I don't think,
really realize that we have a
lot of apps available, right?
We have the ASL app, which
I was thrilled to work on
that provides sign language right.
That can teach you a little bit,
not only about our language,
but also culture, technology
really is amazing.
It really is.
Just talking about children,
there is someone you
quote in the book about
this whole area around
generations and the way that,
that this is, or shouldn't be talked about
and has been in the past,
you quote the view of the man who patented
the first telephone Alexander Graham Bell,
who, despite marrying a deaf woman,
didn't believe deaf people
should marry each other
because of the risk of deaf children.
Why did you include that in the book?
I included it,
I think because it's important
for hearing people to read
and really understand that
deaf issues are not new, right?
That language deprivation
did not arrive recently,
but this has been centuries
and centuries of oppression
and deprivation, you know, in my book,
I really work to outline
the events sort of,
of our history and bring
those to modern day,
which I think a lot of
people don't realize.
But of course what he
was saying, you know, as,
as horrible and unpalatable
as it is to hear, or to say,
I should say, certainly
in this was a lot of the,
the people's view at the
time and may continue to be.
And I just wondered as you're
fourth generation within a
family like that, you know, what,
what is your message on that point,
and also how has it made
you think about your future?
I would say to be honest with you, I,
I would be open to marrying
a deaf or a hearing person.
Right.
You know, I think what's really important
is sort of that connection
but, you know, I think we
should all trust our kids
and certainly ourselves to
know that when we fall in love,
it's, it's right.
You know, I don't think that
we should certainly, you know,
I mean, love is not expensive.
Right? But it's, you know,
available to all of us I think.
I mean, I suppose that
the other question there is
around is around children.
I mean, you may not have got that far
and I'm not meaning to pry,
but when you think about, if
you think about such things,
do you ever think about,
that their lives and how you
would want their lives to be
with your own experiences
and with your siblings?
So I'll tell you, you know,
a big part of deaf culture
is that we wanna be able
to pass it on like any
of our cultures. Right?
We wanna be able to give
our children that sense of
community.
You know, I would love to
have a deaf child, but,
you know,
I think I would really want my
children to know the culture,
to know the community, to
share our language, right.
That beautiful world that I
was lucky enough to grow up in.
I would, of course, wanna pass that on
and I would want them to
carry that same torch.
I recognize this as a
strange question because I,
I'm not comparing the two,
but I sometimes I'm an
only child I get asked,
"Would you have liked siblings?"
And how was that as if it was awful,
but it's the only thing I know.
So I can only say "I'm okay."
It was great. You know, I was okay.
But I was gonna ask you,
because I think people
are curious about this.
Do you think that it is a
better way to live without
hearing,
because you seem to have got
so much from your culture?
I typically tell people,
"I truly don't know any
different much like you," right.
I grew up entirely deaf.
And so I don't really have a
concept of sound or silence.
I mean, I can't hear waves,
but I think they're really beautiful.
And so I think our interpretations
are just a little bit
different and our experience
of those are different.
But I can tell you, you know, I,
of course would love to meet
and work with even more deaf people
who wanna come to the dark side, I guess.
That's one way of putting it.
Have you ever, I don't know if you,
if it is possible for you,
have you ever been interested in trying
any of the technology to help you hear?
Well, funny enough, a
lot of people don't know.
I actually used hearing aids growing up.
But, I hated them not gonna lie.
I absolutely loathed them.
The sound used to gimme
the worst headaches
and my brother who's
deaf loves DJing right.
In his car, he's got
an insane sound system.
He will crank it so loud to the
point where your entire body
is shaking.
And within five, 10 minutes, I'm like,
"Bro, bro, bro, you gotta cut it out,"
because it's so unfamiliar
to me that I seriously,
I end up with a migraine.
So, but that's just me personally.
There's a lot of deaf people
out there who I think can
relate to it and might not be able to.
How interesting, I had no idea
that they could give you
a headache, you know,
in the bid to, to help you hear.
Yep.
That's just, I guess how my hearing works.
It's well, it's, it's
fascinating 'cuz you know,
there are those videos,
you will have seen them,
of a child hearing for
the very first time.
And you know,
I suppose, there is that narrative
that then goes along with
those sorts of videos about
that being a miracle and that
being the goal.
I think a lot of people out
there are very misinformed on
the experience of deaf people, right?
People love those videos.
They love 'em, they're
supposed to feel great,
but it's a few seconds
of another human's life
if you consider it. Right?
You know,
when I consider how I go about
my day and all of the things
that are required for a baby
to be able to hear for the
first time, those two things
are very different, right?
What's important is not the
ability to hear what's important
is the access to language. Right?
And those are two very different
things just because you can
hear something like I could
with hearing aids, doesn't mean
that I would have access
to language. Right?
Of course it's cute.
But I always want to ask people, okay,
"You have this child who's now have
who's now had a hearing aid
or a cochlear implant in,
what sort of resources are you
gonna provide them for the long term?
Is there a,
a phrase or a word that you
think is far better in sign
than spoken?
Ooh,
any phrase
or words?
Oh, I'd have to think about that.
I'd have to,
hmm
oh you know what I have to say?
My favorite sign is monster.
It always has been.
And I just think it looks really cool.
You know, it means so many things,
but it's also slang in the deaf community.
You know, it means like
dope or like good job.
Right. We'll say like, ah, monster.
I love it.
Wait, can we see again?
Yeah, yeah.
Monster.
Great. It's good.
This is, this is a lesson.
I always,
I love knowing what people's
favorite phrases and words are.
So why not ask about sign, right?
Right. No, definitely.
And you know, monster is like a,
it's like a generational slang.
So it's been around, you
know, the, let's say maybe,
you know, young kids, older kids,
maybe they won't know
exactly, but for, you know,
my age group, they all
know like that's our thing.
That's like our, you know, I don't know,
it's a millennial thing.
We all kind of made it up
Nyle, I feel I've been
welcomed in to the crew,
the monster crew briefly.
It's lovely to talk to you and thank you.
Thank you very much.
It's been a real pleasure.
Thank you so much.
And I've had a great time with
you. I hope to do this again.
That would be great.
And thank you, I should
say for being with us
until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.